to people listening or watching around
the world men women at any age right
we're going into a challenging time in
the recession for a lot of people right
depending on you know what side of the
fence you're on playing the opportunity
and a lot of people you know especially
in this generation get swayed by social
media people you know influences like
never before right I mean it was
challenging like you said in your 20s to
figure it out imagine if you had all
these you know influxes of ideas and do
this and do that click the link below
the webinar this or that what advice
would you have to men or women around
the world and maybe pursuing their dream
their Vision maybe that younger version
of a pat who's looking for answers and
trying to win not short term but long
term you know what would you know pbd's
best piece of advice be to sort of find
your lane and play the long game to win
be yeah so so that's a great question so
so everybody watching this Falls in uh
one of three different places okay one
is
um they're sitting on no cash right now
they're in a bad situation with their
house it's upside down they bought their
house at the worst possible time which
means they're 300 000 down or 200 000
down you know they got fired they were
in real estate they were in mortgages
they did not save they're not prepared
so there's nothing they can do to take
advantage of this crisis because they
have no dry you know gun you know
nothing they're not sitting on any cash
okay if you're that person you have to
play a different game then there's the
other person that plays it always safe
okay whether the economy is good bad
ugly it's always like this okay and you
know hey so any opportunities no no no
what if what if what if hey crisis is
happening oh my gosh what if what if
what if and they just kind of play this
game oh proud or the person that's
sitting right now on a lot of cash and
they've been prepared for this moment
for eight years for nine years for ten
years for whatever okay so the first one
guess what you can't do nothing about
this season right not to take advantage
of it you have to prepare for the next
one that's probably going to come up in
the next five to ten years which means
what which means
stack cash all of those people that were
saying cash is trash two years ago are
now saying cash is King again right so
it's so funny that the Cassius trash
Community has converted into the Cash's
King Community today right now the the
tough part is Omar to
stay disciplined to realize cash is King
two years before cash is King right
that's what's hard right and then to
deploy and say let's go for it if you're
trying to add another zero to your
network you're worth your worth 10 grand
you're gonna go to 100 000 that's a big
deal 10 200 Grand I remember the first
time I had a hundred thousand dollars in
a bank that's a lot of money right or
you have a hundred grand you want to go
to a million adding to zero person
that's got a hundred thousand dollars on
the maximum you mean to tell me I'm
gonna have a million that's a very big
deal so that's the next strategy to go
to you got a million and want to go to
10 10 200 102 billion billion to 10
billion it doesn't matter you're all
chasing that next you're in the pursuit
of the next zero right okay so the first
group find another person that did it
right
go bring as much value as you can to
that person that's an up-and-coming star
what do I mean by an up and coming start
right now Elon Musk is looking for a
seal of Twitter right I I talked to a
bunch of different people that are very
close to him most likely know who's
going to end up becoming the CEO of
Twitter a guy named David Sachs you know
how Dave you know why David Sachs is
most likely going to end up becoming the
CEO of Twitter he trusts uh David the
most David's been close to him and
eventually guys like that end up hiring
people that they trust because you mean
to tell me I'm going to give the company
to somebody that I just spent 44 billion
dollars of my money to a stranger and
say hey yeah yeah go ahead you do it
yeah I trust you it's not gonna happen
it's going to be the cause should I
imagine if Elon is 38 years old 42 years
old 36 years old and you go work for a
guy like that and you know this guy's
going to be somebody well the next 5 10
15 20 years say he doesn't work out with
you and Elon guess what's going to
happen you're going to learn a ton from
being around Elan for two years three
years five years that's going to help
you where elsewhere how many people from
the PayPal Mafia build all these other
companies the Jack dorsey's the Peter
Thiel the elamas all of these guys work
together because they knew Reed Hoffman
I want to say all of these guys became
billionaires so PayPal sold for only a
billion and a half
PayPal only sold for a billion an app
you know how much everyone to Elon 180
out of the 180 you put 100 million
dollars into into a SpaceX 17 to Tesla
10 and two
the solar solar company that he put is
so but it's not like he got a bunch of
money so if it's one and a half billion
dollars and that one and a half billion
was split between him Phil Hoffman you
know all these other guys one became
Yelp one became Twitter one became what
what if you're in that PayPal Mafia so
if I'm in the first category man I'm
Gonna Make a list of 30 names
that you can say this guy's word five I
think is going to be worth 100 one day
there's something unique about this guy
let me get in and let me get close to
these guys I want to get into that game
if I ever wanted to make it in Hollywood
that's the first thing I would if I
wanted to get into Hollywood I would
make a list of guys that make movies
together a crew guys and girls I make
movies to you know it's okay these guys
make movies together these guys make
movies together these guys make movies
together man I don't I'm not these guys
but I'm I love these eight guys let me
find out exactly what I need to do to go
here what acting school do they go to
where are they at on Tuesday nights what
club do they go to what I want to get in
because once I go and listen just give
me two lines
and then boom kill it with the two
lights hey Pat we got four lines for you
for that's awesome hey you got a good
roll fifth part uh you're gonna you got
28 Lines no yeah two hundred
thousand dollars hey you're gonna get a
pardon no way yes and then now it's like
other people are seeing you sound
effects Compound Effect so if you're
group one find that one community and
group to get into if you are in group
one okay if you're in group two you can
play in fear for the rest of your life
you're just gonna live a regular life
you have to kind of make a decision to
overcome some of the ways that some of
your philosophies and your identity
there's a reason why you have an
identity flaw and that identity issue
that you're so afraid you need to kind
of take some risks if you're comfortable
if you're not keep living your safe life
it is what it is the other person that's
got money
you have an opportunity right now to add
the additional zero and not only that
you have an opportunity right now to
kind of uh you know maybe even add more
than that because
we have not had this kind of an economy
in 13 years you have to realize we had
129 months of economic expansion which
is 10 years 10 and a half years that's
never happened in the history of the US
economy
and then some of the people are like oh
this is going to last forever boom boom
boom this year oh real estate's not
going to drop really yeah okay no
problem sure you keep believing that
real estate's not going to drop Waterson
Wall Street Journal yesterday experts
are expecting a very difficult time in
real estate in 2023 of course it's going
to happen you can't just increase the
rates thinking I'm going to be able to
afford the same mortgage payment the
average person doesn't buy a house they
sound alone a month they buy based on a
mortgage payment so there's going to be
a lot of opportunities four million out
of homes
will be three million out of homes I'll
give you a perfect example this building
down here I won't give the name because
I may buy this building this building
down the street here I'll tell you about
it afterwards is a 54 million dollar
building
the company was public they decided to
go private
the owner becomes a billionaire okay
two billionaire a 54 million dollar
building is worth what it's just 54
million dollars two billionaire right
so eight months ago I go meet with these
guys and
they're they're asking for 32 million
bucks so they just want to get rid of it
because it's not helping them out with
their you know new investors they said
hey uh you make an offer for 32 million
we'll sell it to you so now I'm at 26.
ciao don't even make the offer so waste
your time no problem you know what
quality and you could do it at 32 but
100 yeah so so they said 26 months I
said no I'm convinced Market's going
down
they called me yesterday
listen man I'm not interested hey Pat
just just listen I'm telling you I'm not
interested can you just take the damn
call
30 seconds
if you make a 20 million dollar offer
right now they'll sell it to you so
guess what I said 15 million
just for the sake of sport because you
could have said yes and you didn't the
name he mentioned when I first walked in
here so big realtor guide okay I made an
offer on one of his buildings one of his
houses at 21.4 million
he comes back he lowers it from 25
million to 24.2 million
I made an offer for 21.4 million
he comes down only five hundred thousand
dollars you know exactly what I'm
talking about I run into many events in
Miami
he says to me oh man that could have
been your house I said no I found out
what you sold it for you sold it for 17
million you could have got an additional
four and a half million but you played
cocky and I told you don't call me again
before Lauren get a half a million I'm
not doing deal with a guy like you and
he walks and he said oh you remember I
said I saw it on real deal you sold it
for 17 million here it is
oh yeah you're right well you effed
up cost Yourself four and a half million
dollars to the seller and make sure the
seller doesn't find it because you cost
them four and a half million dollars and
you cost yourself around 250 000 in
commissions what's the moral of the
story
this is a great time if you got cash
because it's a weird time if you got
cash so many weird opportunities so uh
it's it's uh some people say hi how
could you do that to take advantage of
this it's not to take advantage of this
you would do the same thing if you
stayed disciplined for 20 years to save
money for a moment like this it's
probably because you've been waiting for
this moment so you can capitalize well
it's here five hundred thousand dollar
watches are selling for 210 Grand
today okay
this is just the beginning because one
of the things our friend what's his name
is your best friend Jerome Powell right
one of the things he's made it very
clear is what they are not lowering
the rates this year they're going to
keep it the waiters until inflation gets
to what two points okay to do that what
does it need to do it needs to keep
increasing the more he increases what
happens to a 30-year fixed it keeps
going higher and higher and higher you
think that's going to be you know right
now year over year you know how much
refinance business is down do you know
the number year over year if you were
doing a hundred loans a month a year ago
a year ago correct me if I'm wrong here
this is Wall Street Journal data if
you're doing a hundred and lows as long
as a month a year ago what do you think
you're doing today
20. you're right 86 percent you're down
which means you're doing you're doing 14
a month so let me let me break down the
math for you if you were making a
hundred thousand dollars a month
a year ago doing loans what are you
making right now 20-ish 14 Grand a month
or 10 yeah
that's that's insane and they're saying
he's going to continue increasing rates
what's going to happen real estate well
there's gonna be a lot of great
opportunities so that that stuff so
again if the first group is sitting here
saying oh my God I feel like I feel
like this the great thing about business
is man you know we all have moments
where we miss it I missed out on the
everything being discount on 911 I
missed out uh I was spending most of my
money gambling casinos partying clubbing
and I said I'm going to be ready for the
next one and I was ready for the one in
08 and I was ready for the one in covet
and I am ready for this one year so this
is the whole reason we're going back to
the interview of long-term thinking if
you're thinking long term you're going
to get plenty of chances
thank you